it is incredibly hard
just to allow the possibility that it's
a mystery
and not to feel the urge
to get the answer it is incredibly hard
but it's possible and it is liberating
as recovering is recovering addict to
knowledge let me say
what you gain from it for instance I
understand the value of paradoxes I I
appreciate paradoxes more and you know
to to use another philosopher Soren
kirkegar the Danish philosopher said uh
I think or without Paradox is like a
lover without passion
what's a good line all right
so and you know
Niels Bohr Niels Bohr said
um in similar being the great Danish
also something about that something
about Danes I think it's all started
with scramble it you know
he said the opposite of a simple truth
is a falsity team
but the opposite of a great truth
is another great truth
in other words
things are not black and white you know
they're not
and I would even venture to say the most
interesting interesting things in life
I like that the ones which are ambiguous
it's an electron a particle or a wave
it depends how you set up an experiment
it will reveal itself as this or that
depending on how you set up an
experiment
this bottle if you project it down onto
the table
you will see more or less a square if
you're projected onto a wall you will
see a different shape a naive question
would be is it this or that
because we understand that it's neither
but both projections reveal something
they're real different sides of it a
paradox is like that it's only
paradoxical
um if we if we are confined in a
particular
Vision if we are wedded to a particular
point of view
it's a Harbinger if you will of a
possibility of seeing things uh in a
more in in a as they are as a more
sophisticated than we thought before you
see this is such a difficult idea for
science to Grapple with that you know I
don't know how there's so many ways to
describe this but you could say maybe
that the subjective experience of the
world
from an observer is actually fundamental
but we know that our best physical
theories tell us that unambiguously in
quantum mechanics actually you know
Heisenberg I think captured it the best
when he said what we observe is not
reality itself
but reality
subjected to our method of questioning
um when I talk about uh electrons for
instance so that there is a very
specific way in which you in which this
is realized there is a so-called double
slit experiment right so
um for those who don't know it's you you
have a you have a screen and and you
have an emitter from which you send you
kind of throw shoot electrons and in
between you put another screen which has
two vertical slits parallel to each
other if we were shooting you know
tennis balls each ball would go through
one slit or another and then hit the
screen behind
this or that slit so you would have
let's say they colored they painted so
they'll be sort of bumps or or or spots
of paint behind this or that
but that's not what happens when we
shoot electrons we see an interference
pattern as if we were actually sending a
wave so that each electron
it seems like the each electron goes
through both slits at once and then and
then has the audacity to interfere with
it with itself where at some points you
know two crests would amplify and at
some points aggress in the draft would
cancel each other
yet so that suggests okay so no electron
is a wave not so fast because if you put
a detector behind one of the slits and
you say I'm going to I'm going to
capture you
I am going to find out which lid you
went through the pattern will change and
it will look like the particles so
that's a very concrete realization of
the idea that depending on how we set up
an experiment we will see different
results
and the problem the problem is that our
psyche I feel kind of lagging is lagging
behind in part because maybe our
scientists are not doing such a great
job so I take responsibility for this
that why haven't I explained this
properly you know I I tried you know in
a bunch of talks and so on so now I'm
talking about this again
our psychic kind of lagging behind we're
still even though our science has
progressed so much from the certainty
and the determinism and and all of that
of the 19th century
our psyche is somehow still attached to
those ideas the ideas of causality of
this naive determinism that that the war
the world has a bunch of billiard balls
hitching each other driven by some blind
forces you know that's not at all like
this and we've known this for over for
well for about 100 years at least you
know and you call this self-imposed
limitation it is a self-imposed
limitation when we when we pretend that
uh that for instance that this naive
ideas of 19th century
um physics are still valid and and then
start applying them to our lives and
then also derive conclusions from it and
for instance people say there is no free
will why
because the world is just a bunch of uh
billiard balls where is the free will
but excuse me didn't you get the memo
that this has been debunked thoroughly
by the so-called quantum mechanics which
is our best scientific theory this is
not some some kind of or some
kind of you know
concoction of of a of a Madman this is
our scientific theory which has been
confirmed by experiment so we should pay
attention to that so but of course it's
not just
um self-imposed limitation unfortunately
in this case there is a big issue of
Education
so a lot of people are not aware of it
through no fault of their own because
they were never properly taught that
because our system is broken education
system is broken especially in math
and then our so where do we get do you
get information you get information from
our scientists who actually write
popular books and so on which is a great
you know
um great thing that they do but a lot of
scientists somehow
um when it comes to explaining the laws
of physics they are doing a fantastic
job
um talking about this phenomenon for
instance double slit experiments and
things like that but then you know
interviewed by Science magazine about
Freewheel and so on they revert back to
19 19th century physics as if those
developments actually never happened so
to me this is single most
important sort of issue in our
Popular Science
the idea that somehow there is this
world out there but it's complete has
nothing to do with me so I can I can
reveal in the
intricacies of these particles and their
interactions
but but completely ignore what
implications this has
for my own relationship to the physical
reality to my own life you know because
it's kind of scary I guess you know but
also what are the tools
with which we can talk about the
Observer
the subjective view in reality what are
the tools of which we could talk about
rigorously talk about Free Will and
Consciousness what are the tools of
mathematics that allow that I don't
think we have those tools because we
haven't been taught properly so actually
tools are there for instance
um
I think well
here we have to
I have to say my conviction is that
everybody knows
in the heart of hearts everybody knows
that there is that there is something
in a football there is something
mysterious and in fact you know
somehow immediately I feel that
um you know the impulse to quote
somebody on this because as if as if my
own opinion doesn't occur
there's a long dead expert that has been
Einstein said that he doesn't like how
see look at me I have supposedly like
this smart intelligent person
I am afraid to say it and own it myself
I have to find a confirmation I have to
find an authority who agrees with me and
in fact it's not so difficult to find
because Albert Einstein literally said
the most important thing in life is the
mysterious okay he actually said that
there are some quotes which are
attributed to him which he never said
but this he did I investigated okay so
but more importantly you know
how do you feel about it
um I think that everybody knows
but
in other words he also said Einstein
imagination is more important than
knowledge okay and it's explained for
knowledge is always limited
whereas the imagination Embraces the
entire world giving birth to Evolution
it is uh strictly speaking a real factor
in scientific research he says and he
says I am enough of an artist to follow
my intuition and Imagination that's
Albert Einstein again so and I feel the
same way to be honest if I think about
my own mathematical research
it's never linear
it's never like give me more data give
me more data give me more data Boom the
glass is full and then I come up with a
discovery no it's always it always is
always felt as a jump as a leap